you are a part of like
a generation of artists where
your peers are dying are dying for sure
at like a rate that we've never seen in
hip hop is this more than like that 96
98 era right yeah for sure not even
close yeah it's not even close no for
sure like does that like you know i mean
i always tell likes i have some close
friends
that i you know i'll just be like yo you
got to chill because like i don't want
to wake up one day and like you're out
of town and you get shot or something
like yeah it's [ __ ] up
it's a wild time like
and i feel like you're like like i said
like you're kind of one of the bright
lights
in our culture where it's like
you're not
promoting certain things you're not
you're not in into a lot of [ __ ]
you're not stirring up [ __ ] on the
internet you're not talking about
drug use [ __ ] like that but like
like is is it like what you know
these are your peers these are people
you know these are people who you've
seen at parties like yeah for sure it's
sad because
nobody can relate to you like other
artists can we all are
our peers like you said we all appears
and co-workers in this ecosystem of
music
and so to see people that you're on like
um early shows where they've done early
tours whether you've seen them at
festivals or you know juice world
was the only one i was like really like
genuine close with right in a real real
way like really my like one of my
closest friends but just seeing you know
like the dolph situation that broke my
heart um
and how many others said i can't even
think of everybody at the top of my head
it's crazy it's crazy yeah it's like it
feels like once every like
60 days it's like what the [ __ ] what is
happening it's it's it's a wild time man
that's ridiculous